[Music]
hi guys and welcome to yet another
episode of congratulations
[Music]
here we are here we are hello darkness
my old friend
a waiter can't you see again
and yodello lo lo nio
load loaded
and sometimes you'll never know the
basic facts here again
and the sounds of summer or whatever the
[ __ ] i have no idea but um
i will say dude that uh i will be in
grand prairie texas [ __ ] yeah yeehaw
dude we throw out yee haws in grand
prairie texas and that's gonna be in
dallas well it's a dallas play and i say
that because i don't know i mean i'm
sure if you live in dallas you know
about grand prairie texas but i don't so
i say it's a dallas play
uh i'm playing the texas trust cu
theater too many words in that huh but
i'm doing that august 26th so go to
crystallia.com to get tickets and then
i'm going to be in wichita kansas for
some reason at the orpheum theater uh
the day after
chrissalia.com for tickets and then i'm
going to be in atlanta georgia and i'm
going to be in washington dc in
september stockton california oakland
california september 23rd and 24th and
then october i have peoria illinois and
rockford illinois
and then i have raleigh north carolina
and then i have savannah georgia
and then in november i have dis uh sorry
almost saturday november i have december
which is absolutely [ __ ] idiotic but
i have december colorado november 5th
crystallia.com and then cheyenne wyoming
i'm going the next day
november 6th and then boston
massachusetts you know the boston babies
come out for your boy so he added
another show boston massachusetts at the
wang theater
and then he's going to lakeland florida
for some reason and jacksonville for
some reason december 2nd and december
3rd chrisley.com so come on out and do
the show and come to the show and wear
the merch chrisleya.com for merch you
know what's up
drinking lacroix
somebody asked me about uh a comedian a
filipino comedian i said it's jokoy and
then they said joe lacroix and i said
nope and that was
honestly
funny for like [ __ ] one hour but um
joe lacroix uh
so
what's up dude
uh chilling absolutely chilling
um i
have spent all day not feeling funny and
not being sure if i could do this
podcast but your boy has a job you know
what your boy has jerk which is what
calvin says so gotta go to jerk where's
datta going jerk and every night i say
hey buddy you know where dad's going and
he says jurk and then he leans in he's
playing with the toys and he leans in
because he for a kiss and i give him a
kiss and i say see you and he says
bye-bye dada and it warms my heart
um
so yeah
so it's a little bit more like in that
times it's a little bit more like hello
lightness my old friend but um
yeah and not so much darkness but that's
what's up um
so yeah life's been okay you know we've
been having a good time um i gotta be
honest man uh i put up a story the other
day on my instagram about how my ocd was
just [ __ ] killing me
and i don't normally post stuff like
that
uh because you know i don't i don't know
if social media is supposed to be for
you know emoting so much but i know a
lot of people do it and they feel it and
and and it's good for them and and it's
their it's their brand and it's not
really mine
uh because i just kind of come on here
and [ __ ] and i do jokey stuff and i
talk about like [ __ ] hugh jackman but
like um
you know i i i was really
i was taken aback by how many people
um
[Music]
were struggling with that as well um i i
basically um
i couldn't leave
the house i couldn't get out uh i was
just stuck in a loop and i don't know if
you know how serious uh you know i make
light of it a lot but like
i really have uh a [ __ ] pretty
hard case of ocd and sometimes
it's [ __ ] real tough um and i was
just stuck dude i was stuck in my house
and i couldn't leave i couldn't move
um and my anxiety was just [ __ ]
killing me it was getting the best of me
and
uh it was anxiety and ocd and i was
[ __ ] i was just i
i think i had therapy earlier and i was
just really really really
just struggling and i finally got out of
the house um
at like three
which is so late for me man
and it was so [ __ ] hard um
and i was just [ __ ] up all day uh
and i just i was just taken aback by how
many people reached out and said like i
i really appreciate you sharing this
because it's a struggle too it's nice to
know that like you suffer from this i
mean not not this nice to know that
anybody suffers from it but like that
like they're not alone i guess um but
yeah man i you know i think that
sometimes
it's weird because the internet like
looks at people i don't mean to get so
[ __ ] i usually like to start with
some [ __ ] funny [ __ ] but like
it's weird to see that like some people
like on the internet especially like
celebrities you know you see them
getting dragged for all sorts of [ __ ]
and like just people think that their
lives are amazing like i look at like
guys like
the rock or
whoever um and i just wonder what their
life is really like
because
you know he's a person and i know it's
go go go but
all it takes is like a certain
moment to just realize oh [ __ ] man i've
been really going too hard or really
been not taking care of myself and my
mental
and uh i think that that's important you
know sometimes you coast through therapy
or sometimes like i go to my meetings
and i like i i i don't know i feel like
i'm on autopilot or something but like
i don't know it just hit me that i was
not like
taking care of myself
and i just had a [ __ ] rough few days
man um i went on stage and i kind of
tried to get through it i thought it
would get better and um you know it's up
and down but
um i just want people to know that like
i'm
i know that like you come to me for like
humor and [ __ ] and i said i wasn't
feeling funny today
i just really appreciate you guys
listening because like um and i feel
like you know since the response from my
post which i don't normally share i mean
i even had like some like celebrities
reach out and they were like oh you know
yeah i suffer from the same thing and it
was just like wow
you know it was nice for me to know that
i'm not alone you know because i think
sometimes people look at people who have
2 million followers and they're like
that guy knows what the [ __ ] life's all
about it's just like it's a constant
[ __ ]
thing where you're trying to figure out
you're trying to grow and you're trying
to understand yourself and
how you're
uh managing your life and it's not
perfect and it's [ __ ] messy and um
so
you know um
yeah you're not alone dude i i my ocd
was [ __ ] killing me man like [ __ ] i
don't even like thinking about it but
it was a [ __ ] struggle
um
you get stuck in like a loop and i don't
even want to like
get out it's hard for me to even leave a
room because i leave a room and i get
terrified like
dude i leave a room and i get [ __ ]
terrified that i left the room the wrong
way or something or like i left
something in a wrong way and somebody's
gonna die or get cancer or some [ __ ] or
whatever the [ __ ] man something's gonna
happen to my family and it's [ __ ] so
weird
[ __ ]
i never see that [ __ ] movie with hugh
jackman with the robots
where he's just like [ __ ] what's that
robot [ __ ] thing were they punching
they're punching [ __ ] heads and [ __ ]
what is it called real real deal dude
real steal
[ __ ] was that
[Laughter]
[ __ ] hugh jackman gonna be making
that movie and i'm [ __ ] trapped in my
[ __ ] bedroom
i'm just gonna be making real steel
while i'm [ __ ] thinking about how my
whole family's getting cancer when i
turn on the goddamn shower [ __ ] off
you're just gonna make real steel huh
yeah what's it about robots all right
well let's make it is crystalline stuck
in a room all right and
action [ __ ] being ripped this [ __ ]
just so ripped on [ __ ] tea
all right
i've only eaten meat and [ __ ] lettuce
reps
just get off the set of wolverine
let's make a movie with robots hold on i
need to check something is crystallized
trapped in a [ __ ] room because he
can't leave without thinking his
family's gonna die in an airplane
air right and action
so don't think i'm gonna be all [ __ ]
walls down the whole time and not bring
up [ __ ] goddamn hugh jackman and some
of his [ __ ] ass movies
to [ __ ] even it out baby because we
gotta even it out dude the walls go down
you start with the waterworks well hugh
jackman's getting it immediately dude
all right
and don't think i didn't [ __ ] see
whatever that other one was where he
was trying to
with the whip and the [ __ ] hat that
like what's his name would wear
from the gorin brothers
the [ __ ] one where where he's
doctor he meets dr jekyll mr hyde and
frankenstein and all the shits
and and [ __ ]
the [ __ ] it
god damn it
hugh jackman with the long hair and kate
beckinsale's in it
captain pink himself in it
ben helsing dude whoa
and isn't that a [ __ ] because i
took two gabapentin today and that's why
i forgot van helsing dude but whatever
dude the walls come down and we make fun
of hugh jackman and that's how we culp
because that is how we cope with with
humor and i realize i just want people
to like me man
you know
why can't that come from me right
i don't know
i don't know
i don't know you sit and you talk to
your therapist and you ask them why am i
like this you know it's like that
[ __ ] meme with the guy in the mirror
where's like why are we like this
that's me dude that's me at therapy why
am i like this and she's just like well
why don't you take me back to day one
and i'm just like don't pull that hacky
[ __ ] with me man oh really my childhood
okay
really that hacky [ __ ]
so i gotta talk about how [ __ ] trauma
happens over a long period of time
because i was never [ __ ] fingered you
know
it wasn't one immediate thing that
happened it was just overtime right
so uh yeah
uh yeah just trying to figure it out
dude so what i'm trying to say is real
steel is [ __ ] terrible no matter what
no matter what you think no matter what
they think and most of the time the
feel-good movie of the year is not the
feel-good movie of the year okay that's
all i'm saying that's why i'm saying top
gun can't be as good as it [ __ ]
possibly am i even making any sense why
do you listen dude [ __ ] why am i like
this
why do you even why do we listen my
babies
um
i'll tell you what i started this
podcast because i wanted to talk about
[ __ ] [ __ ] i want to talk about
silly things and that's it and then you
got to know me and whoopsie daisy okay
now you know me a little bit and i don't
know how to [ __ ] keep doing this
podcast i got to keep talking right
i got to keep talking and now you're
going to know about all my life and
everything and all the [ __ ]
stuff going on in my head but whatever
dude
uh at least i [ __ ]
you know what i tried to do the other
day i looked at my son
and uh
i often tell my son i love you bud
i but i often say it like
do you know how much i love you you know
some [ __ ] like that do you know how much
dad dad loves you
and i was like you know what dude he's
two i'm gonna [ __ ] say it like a 40
year old
like a 40 year old telling another
[ __ ]
who's 40. i love you
i'ma pull no punches
so i walk up to him
and i say hey calvin come here and he's
playing with like [ __ ] napkin holders
or some [ __ ] he's got 900 toys he's
playing with jingly napkin holders
and uh
you know or he's playing with that
[ __ ] little fish magnet game where
he's trying to do the fish but he's
getting real frustrated because he can't
do it and and then kristen told him to
just put it on the refrigerator and and
now it's just a magnet on the
refrigerator and she was like it's magic
and he now he's like um i'm like great
now he believes in it okay
good now he believes in [ __ ] magic
good
now he's gonna believe in magic dude you
know who also believes in magic me when
i turn on the shower i think my family's
gonna die in a plane crash how about
that that's magic so great now we
started ocd with calvin now [ __ ]
calvin's sitting there he's gonna be
like where are the portals mom when he's
eight
he's gonna believe in [ __ ] gizzards
and i say gizzards because that's how he
says wizard
so uh he puts the [ __ ] magnet on the
thing and then she's like look magic dad
that look what i did magic and for the
first time he put the [ __ ] thing in
the refridge and he [ __ ] looked at me
like what do you think dude that was
cute as [ __ ] so i'm like i might tell
him i love him i'm gonna tell him i love
him like a 40 year old does another 40
year old he loves him
and so i look i look him in the eyes and
i said kevin i got to tell you man i
love you i love you i love you so much
do you know i love you so much i love
you so much
and i love my job you know how much dad
loves his job when he goes to work
and he said yeah and i said i love you
more
than that and it doesn't even compare
how much more that's how much i love you
i would give up anything for you i love
you that much i love you more than
anything in this world
and you know what he said
he looked at me right in the eyes and he
said
i guess i need a raisin and walked away
is there anything
more like seriously think about it
any out of any age group is there
anything more
disrespectful to respond to to that
sentence
is there anything more disrespectful
to not even be first of all ray who the
[ __ ] eats raisins right whoever even
wants a raisin
raisins are [ __ ] horseshit you know
what i mean
every time i see raise it when's that
time you ate a dude if you've eaten a
raisin in the last [ __ ]
i don't know 10 years
i mean i get i get it if you're just
like in the 90s eating raisins because
like you saw a [ __ ] uh
what a [ __ ] commercial where people
are like running around in fields with
sunlight peak you know what i mean i
don't know like what's that [ __ ]
raisin
seems like that would be a raisin
commercial but like there's no raisin
commercials now anymore you know don't
eat raisins
and so like i say i love you so much i
love you more than anything more than my
job which by the way is a step for me
because i thought i had to like comedy
more than anything to be good at comedy
i thought that
up until my family became what's
important
i thought that stand-up was the goal
but it's not
[ __ ] all that [ __ ]
family right
so now this is a step for me and i tell
him and i'm already like wow i'm making
progress in my life admitting to my
two-year-old that hey your dad
loves you more than anything
and this dude not only does he want to
ra he is not even sure he wants the
[ __ ] raisin
that's how disrespectful it is he's it
would be
light years more respectfully he was
like so you know what i'm hungry for a
raisin but he was just [ __ ] dilly
dallying walking around saying i guess i
need a raisin
the most disrespectful anyone has ever
been to me and i made him
it's like the moment in the godfather
where al pacino is just like don't ask
me about my business kate
don't ask me about my business
it's like the end when she's like i just
want to ask one thing did you kill him
and he says you can ask this one time
you can ask this one question what's the
question and she's like did you kill him
and he looks at her and he says
no
and you know he did
that was my son
i guess i need a raisin
but i just want to tell you i love you
more than anything i love you more than
my job i guess i need a raisin
oh yeah i guess i need a raisin
oh boy
you want to tell me you love me more
than anything
oh yeah
oh
and not nice
i love al pacino dude
the best the best because he's the best
and the worst dude al pacino will be uh
make a [ __ ] dopey [ __ ] ass movie and
then he'll go and make a real some real
shitty movie where he's just acting too
much in it and then he'll [ __ ]
surprise you and play like dr kevorkian
on showtime and you're like whoa bro
where was this
oh yeah euthanasia yeah oh yeah
oh of course i believe in it oh i know
it's against the law but i think it's
right
isn't that right clergy man how many
times has he sent something like that
and
dude al pacino only picks me i said this
but i must have said this before
alpacino only picks movies where he
could do long monologues that make no
sense until the end
he'll play like a [ __ ] movie with his
father with his with his son that's
estranged and and he'll be like it'd be
like dad you want to play catch and
he'll be like do you know how they make
a kobe steak
it's not like a regular burger
they take that cow they get it nice and
drunk
they liquor it up
they massage that cow they get the meat
nice and tender
where's that ball
what
and the award goes to
al pacino in isn't that right clergyman
[Laughter]
you know i wasn't gonna take this roll
but
oh yeah i did just always getting sucked
off you know i wasn't gonna take this
roll but oh my oh yeah ha
sorry i'm busting under the podium
oh all in your mouth
um
oops all over your face
oh i made a mess
[Laughter]
you know after he spunks he does some
crazy [ __ ] like that oh yeah well i made
a mess
um
oopsy daisy call me crazy
and then moon walks back into the
bathroom huh
but you didn't know i know how to do
that clergy man what the [ __ ] girl just
like last time i hooked up with him
he's a [ __ ] insane person
you know how to make a copy site in the
bathroom
um
anyway dude what was i even
oh yeah my son
ah so that's what's up i don't know
i went to [ __ ] jones on third in the
and i go to sometimes i go to jones on
third in the valley but i went to the
one in the in hollywood because i had to
go over and get my contact lenses and
that's in the in the
in hollywood and i just sat down and it
was you know i was having one of those
days it was one of those days i was
struggling and i
and i get the [ __ ] club sandwich you
know how i do it yeah does he ask for
cheese yeah yes for cheese dude club
sandwiches have cheese on him dude but
he knows that the [ __ ] places don't
put cheese on club sandwiches sometimes
so he asks you know what can i have
[ __ ] cheddar cheese on the [ __ ] i
said can i get cheese on the sandwich
and they always say what kind we have
and then they say three kinds and i say
well cheddar dude if you eat a club
sandwich with a [ __ ] provolone then
you're a communist you know that right
so
i got the uh you know the club sandwich
and boy is it [ __ ] unbelievable dude
i mean you eat one bite it's i mean that
[ __ ] goes quick you just i mean it's
good okay all i'm saying is it's good
and i get the thing and i sit down and
i'm like you know what i'm gonna do dude
i'm gonna sit in the sun because i don't
do that dude because your boy's a little
bit you know he's a vampire but also i'm
like the sun rays are gonna make me feel
good
right that's what i'm going to do
because i felt kind of like you know
cloudy and i'm like i'm just going to
sit in the sun and it's going to [ __ ]
make me feel good i'm going to get some
vitamin d
so i sit down in the sun there's shade
but i skipped it there's there's there's
places open to shade i sit next to the
shade i sit in the sun
and then this really old dude comes and
sits down next to me
and uh
he's in the shade and he's you know i
don't know i can't tell sometimes if
people are 65 or 75 but he was one of
those and uh he sits down
and he puts a bag down and he's chewing
something from inside the bag i assume
it's a muffin okay i don't know what it
could be a croissant or a [ __ ]
chocolate croissant
um the [ __ ] up the lines so um
so i say uh
so i sit down and he sits down
and he picks up his phone
and he says
did you get my text and he said he does
what he says did you get my text
oh
yeah nah i'm eating a muffin
yeah
i'll tell you you know what it's
unbelievable and you know what it was 4
15. it was 15 cents but sometimes you
know you just got to say
[ __ ] it
you got to just spring for it and i
don't regret
it for a second
yeah
all right
i'll see you later
that was the conversation
that
that
when i tell you that's my goal
at 70
i can't even like dude four years ago
ago i wanted to be the best comedian i
wanted to be my i wanted to be the best
version of my community bro if i could
just get to the point
where i'm [ __ ]
where i text another old dude for sure
about my muffin and then he calls me and
then i tell him about the muffin and how
i just had to spring for it dude
that's it dude that's smooth [ __ ]
sailing bury me six feet deep that is
the peak dude
that is the peak
and then the guy picked up the phone
again started talking to another friend
and he was like yeah so you know i did a
show at cantor's last night and i'm like
cantor's deli i don't even know kansas
dilly hatcher like what's this
[ __ ] talk about can't be comedy
i was like yeah they got an open mic and
i'm like this guy's an open mic comedian
at 70 years old and he's eating a muffin
that he sprung for and bragging about it
sending pics to his old friends dude the
when i tell you
that's the goal
[Applause]
when i tell you that's the go like dude
you look at these [ __ ] like
the rock and kevin hart the guys who
quote unquote have it all dude i'm stuck
in my room with my ocd and this
motherfucker's bragging about a muffin
when i tell you
that's the goal
[Applause]
and i was proud that he was doing open
mic because i'm a comedian too and here
i am struggling with my ocd sad as [ __ ]
trying to get some vitamin d and he's
just cooling off in the shade
you know i want to say maybe i i didn't
really see myself in them but i was like
oh you know what
we're all in this [ __ ] together dude
we're all in this together
right
[Music]
hey guys when you run a business uh time
it seems more precious am i right i want
to talk to you about ship station it
handles all that every misplaced moment
feels like a missed opportunity a lost
chance if you will to make your business
better or even just to step away and
recharge which matters as well but
shipstation gives ecommerce sellers like
you more time to do
what you really love
unless you really love what you really
love is managing every single little
detail of order fulfillment which i
highly doubt it
shipstation automates time intensive
shipping processes so you can get back
to focusing on bigger things like
developing new products honing your
marketing strategy or interacting with
customers all of the things that
actually really matter
and that you like doing more uh so no
wonder ship station is already trusted
by over what 100
000 sellers what's my favorite thing
about shipstation well i'm glad you
asked i'll tell you less tasks for my
team which means happy fans getting
their merch super duper fast um
yeah they get it sometimes next day i
mean ship station is great uh you gotta
check it out all those manuals shipping
tasks eating up your time ship station
is really good at those so let
shipstation handle it all your shipping
and handling and get back to what you're
good at growing your business all right
so
98 of companies that use shipstation for
a year keep using it for as long as they
stay in business so
you do the math i guess it's very very
good
it's time to let go of all those
shipping tasks shipstation can do it
better and faster sign up using promo
code congrats for a free 60-day trial
today at shipstation.com
and start saving time with every
shipment that's two whole months of
shipping made quick and painless and
it's free to try you like free don't you
so go to shipstation.com
click on the microphone at the top of
the page and type in congrats ship
station make ship happen
[Music]
so we're all in this together is what
i'm trying to say now that was what
happened when i was at jones on third
the [ __ ] old guy who sat down and
started talking about open mic
now after that did somebody say hey man
i love your comedy and i turned around
and i said oh thank you very much and
then he said yeah man what's it like out
there and i was like oh it's great he's
like how was it through the pandemic and
i was like oh it's uh yeah it was good i
didn't really do much you know because
of the pandemic and i didn't [ __ ] get
in there i don't know if he knows really
who i am or what the [ __ ] i just
recognized my face
and he's like oh cool yeah he's like um
and i say all right great man and then i
turn around and then he says um
you got any shows coming up and i'm oh
uh yeah yeah yeah i'm always doing shows
oh yeah where
uh yeah you know just like
pretty much every week laugh factory
improv you know different places oh yeah
yeah yeah so turn around okay cool yeah
great eat my [ __ ] [ __ ] with the you
know with the cheese in it i got that
nice [ __ ] club sandwich and he says
what sign are you
there we go i'm already in it dude right
he lured me in you know what i'm talking
about like he gave me some [ __ ] hi
how you do you how you're doing
conversation some casual [ __ ] like we're
both in some sweatpants right just
chilling hey yeah oh cool
and then boom
broadsided me with what sign are you now
first of all don't ask that
no matter what
okay
be you know why you know why i'm gonna
be straight with you
because
that's it
it's so
gonna just [ __ ] be you want to
connect with me cool but don't ask me
what sign i am do you know i just happen
to know what sign i am i don't really
know except for the reason
that people ask me
what's your sign and a few times in the
beginning i was like i don't know when's
your birthday march 29th oh you're in
aries i say oh okay and they say what's
that you know what that means i say nah
and then he says something about a ram
or fire and i'm like oh cool i'm a power
ranger
so he says what sign are you and i and
i'm already in the conversation right
and so
i say oh i'm in aries and he says oh
yeah bro
uh-huh
and i say yeah and he says yep i [ __ ]
yes
and i was like cool and he says
you know that's just uh
you ever ever look into that stuff
and i say no not at all i don't really
know anything about it except for the
fact that i'm in aries that's really all
i know and he said
bro and he leaned in and he said you got
to look that stuff up it's insane
it's crazy how real it is and when i
first got into it i was not a believer
and now
i [ __ ] look at it all the time it's
unbelievable it makes so much sense and
i go like this
oh [ __ ] huh
well that's crazy man and i go and i
finish my [ __ ]
actually no you know what i did i texted
kristin i was like hey i'm close by if
you want to come by and she [ __ ]
saved me and i just went inside and i
ate no no disrespect to the dude hey
believe what you want and like i said
we're all in this together and that old
guy is also with you that was asking me
what the [ __ ] sign i am so we're all in
this together so you guys have added ask
the guy with the muffin what sign he is
right
so i go in and i sit and i finish the
rest of my turkey sandwich and kristen
meets me and uh you know we have lunch
and it's nice dude it's a little day
date
and she looked very beautiful and i just
took it all in and it was nice i got a
coffee
i forget where she came from like she
was probably doing her hair or some [ __ ]
i don't remember
and um and it was nice
you know
chicks do their hair bro that [ __ ] takes
forever
they're like i'm going to get my hair
done oh okay
and it's you know what do you have
um and you're like i don't know like
cool be back on thursday
what they come back and it's just like
[ __ ]
so gorgeous just popping the [ __ ] out
looking like that dude the the magician
on the movie with [ __ ] steve carrell
and jim carrey
um
how about the [ __ ] uh the bieber
thing jesus christ
bieber's just [ __ ] talking out the
side of his face now i mean not to be
disrespectful i love the i loved it i
love the guy right he's been good to me
i love joseph bieber um but jesus man
that he had that um
the condition of no not the condition
the virus in his ear and it pinched his
nerve and now he can't talk out the side
of half of his face is paralyzed and
that's like one of those things where
it's like
you know
oh oh oh that's a thing
like i know about bell's palsy or
whatever the [ __ ] but like you can just
get a virus in your ear and then all of
a sudden half your face shuts down and
i'm just like oh that's a thing i gotta
worry about not to be self-centered and
egotistical but
[ __ ] justin bieber's getting it i
mean i'm definitely getting something
i mean this guy's out there croon into
the masses i'm out here telling dick
jokes to 200 000 people online
i mean he's croon and [ __ ] guys just
like let me put a little something in
your ear paralyze half your face the
[ __ ] it gonna do to me
this guy's living his true self killing
it out there with haley just having a
great time probably gonna have kids soon
and just living
[ __ ]
right
religious is [ __ ] talking about posting
about god every other [ __ ] hour on
instagram and god's just like you know
what let me give you a little [ __ ]
thing in your ear and his face shuts
down and bieber guess what uses this
probably to believe in god
more
let me tell you something dude
if i get a virus in my ear half my face
shuts down
now
i don't know if there's god or not
but if that happens to me
there's no god for sure
that's where my brain goes
you know how people are like this is
especially like old black man this is a
test you know this is a test from jesus
christ and and you're just like oh
oh
that's why you got shot
by a [ __ ] you know
uh
crossbow
by mistake
it's a test from jesus and you're like
uh uh
the second i get [ __ ] or like uh
stung by a sting or whatever the [ __ ] a
jellyfish or you know and i gotta lie my
leg gets lopped off
oh that's me that's me in my head
confirming there's no god
that's it
a shark attack people come out with one
arm well you know what it made me
stronger and now i know there's jesus yo
you locked my arm off the first thing
i'm saying was thought so knew it
i knew it i knew he was fake
my parents should have told me when they
told me santa wasn't real oh also jesus
bro
justin bieber is a better man than me
right
this guy's like i will get through it
any will it's curable they don't know
how long it takes oh dude that's another
thing they don't know the timeline [ __ ]
all that dude hey doc give me a timeline
oh cr oh sorry mr dalia half your face
is paralyzed and me hey well when's it
going to get better well we don't know
these things yo yo hey doc i want you to
lean in a little bit closer to my good
side
what's the timeline give me one i have
to manually shut my eye to blink
uh
three months
that's what i thought
do you believe in god
[ __ ] that i mean i'm an evil villain if
that happens justin bieber's gonna
become a better person
you gotta forge through the fire right
you gotta do that you really do though
you know
you really do it's hard because you know
it's easy to get beat up in life and let
it [ __ ] you know be the victim
and and and [ __ ] but you know when i'm
sitting there stuck in a room i can't
let my ocd win right
so i went out and i got that
[ __ ] coffee
and caffeinated it all up and talked to
a [ __ ] and heard a guy on the phone
talk about a muffin and then got
bothered by a guy it's just life dude
got bothered by a guy with a [ __ ] ask
me what sign i am that's just life baby
and it's good we're all in this together
man
you know
it's interesting
it's also hot as [ __ ] in here that's
great
i love undecided [ __ ] great [ __ ] yeah
sweating awesome
it's [ __ ] huge news dude
[ __ ] so sweaty mine pits are [ __ ]
i need to hold buckets under it that's
[ __ ] huge news dude yes [ __ ] yeah
dude
[ __ ] yeah dude
let's watch this one [ __ ] thing
that came out classic 90s the kid's
guide to the internet dude
i've never seen this before and i can't
believe it
it's from this is my tech well that's
what posted it on us who posted on
youtube
um
[Music]
here we go
hey there nothing more 90s than that one
second dude
a [ __ ] recorder
hey guys
she's got a mock turtleneck on ah
sir
90s
you on a razor scooter
what's your favorite show friends
again this is my brother peter mom and
dad that's me that's literally just how
i look jesus christ dude i literally
look like that kid right there
unbelievable wore the same [ __ ] baggy as
[ __ ] jeans dude that's me bro
that's what they want you to think
that's you because they want you to
relate to it well guess what [ __ ]
kid's guide to the internet you did it
we're going to be showing our friends
andrew and lisa the basics of the
internet and we thought you might want
to come along it'll be cool now here's a
little background when we install i
murdered a computer i got there's a
little background involved it's true
everybody had their own tasks to do it
was a lot of work but it was really
worth it wow i mean you know it was a
lot of work but i was really worth it
what would just happen did you make a
noise oh no i didn't hear it
well it was a lot of work but it was
really worth it not a lot of work you
know
you hit on
is that it right
now that i've gotten on the internet i'd
rather be on my computer than doing just
about anything it's really i mean
they're actually that's a good thing
dude wow in the 90s that was the [ __ ] oh
good he's gonna get a lot of work done
[ __ ] closes the door be out be out
after dinner
[ __ ] just spanking off to some
[ __ ]
just figuring it out just online
figuring it out you know just [ __ ]
out just in in his dad's office just
spanking just
figuring it out you know
just figuring out everything all the
emotions exploring and i don't mean the
[ __ ] world wide web just [ __ ] yeah
i'll be right out dude whenever the
internet happened in the beginning i
would [ __ ] first of all i aimed it up
aim dude alleycats27 or whatever the
[ __ ] my username was
um
and uh
i would just go in chat rooms what's up
i'm out
haha
anyone like cars i'm out pow
sup who's your favorite ninja turtle bam
leave before they even answer dude i
don't give a [ __ ] what's alicat 27 going
to say
who gives a [ __ ] what you gonna say
raphael i'm out already
age sex location
just pop in one room got a boner leave
do you know what i mean
anyone out there looking for some fun
bam leave before the [ __ ] 50 year old
man replies yes
bro i'm out you know but i would do the
[ __ ] internet and then i would do my
mom every time it was unbelievable she
would ask me how to do the internet and
i would sign her on to aol and it would
[ __ ] be
um
[Applause]
welcome you've got mail
and then she'd be like thanks i'd be
like so that's your mailing thing and
then okay cool and then head away okay
and then and then how do i okay and then
this and then okay and there's no it's
in the icon just drag it over okay you
got it yeah i'd leave every time i left
i walked down the hallway i think oh
[ __ ] christopher
bro when i say my blood boiled because i
know it was overdramatic and didn't and
she didn't need to be doing that now of
course did that create deeper issues for
me yes okay
but i would be like mom it's fine i'll
walk back in what did i do okay so what
did i do you look you just minimized it
that's all you did all you got to do is
click out over here okay that's it she
minimized it dude if moms weren't
minimizing pages what else the [ __ ] were
they doing in the 90s by mistake oh [ __ ]
christopher oh what did i do from the
other room and me just goddamn
[ __ ]
okay coming
can you leave so i can [ __ ]
figure it out and i don't mean the world
wide web
i remember one time my friend came over
tim chung
and uh by the way i mentioned tim chung
one time in this podcast before and tim
chung hit me up uh no actually he i saw
him on a 20-year reunion in my high
school and he was like hey man did you
mention me on your podcast one time i
said oh yeah i think so and he said dude
i [ __ ] everyone been hit me up i'm
like whoa dude that's the baby's going
at him man
hell yeah i hadn't talked to tim in a
long time anyway tim
he was a really good basketball really
short asian guy really good basketball
player in high school was super jealous
of that but
he um
what the [ __ ] story was i gonna say oh
yeah he came over and i was showing him
like my [ __ ] my porns on the [ __ ]
aol right
and i remember the the he was like
uh
oh man that's not good you should you
should you should delete these and i was
like yeah no i don't know and he was
like yeah but but you know it's bad
because like we should be like living
for jesus christ and i was like yeah i
know but
you know
tits
you know
he was like no i know he's like well
let's delete them so i deleted a bunch
of them
and then the last one i remember was
like one that i really liked it was a
picture of a [ __ ]
of a lady just
open just [ __ ] open for business dude
like it was just a lady just [ __ ]
straight up just basically a [ __ ]
deli at noon
just open his [ __ ]
just [ __ ] tits out nothing on but a
[ __ ] nurse's cap just nothing the
sexiest thing to do is to cover
something that you don't even think of
during sex like the top of your head
and everything else just [ __ ]
straight up a daily at noon just welcome
right just open the [ __ ] up right just
fried butterfly just
freed up you know what i mean
any and ice and he says oh man and i
said yeah this is my favorite one
and he says we got to delete it and i
was like oh but i don't know it's like
my favorite one and he's like come on
let's do it for jesus and i go you're
right and the next thing i heard was
and you gotta do it again you know you
gotta go
otherwise it's still in the trash
[ __ ] man she was open like a deli at
noon wasn't she
all right
and then tim left and then a week later
i downloaded a whole bunch of more
pictures of porns
but whatever dude for jesus christ you
know
jesus christ
i needed to
figure it out and i'm not talking about
the [ __ ] world wide web i'm talking
about myself dude needed to see what
happened with that old [ __ ] bra cat
cat
gave us a whole world of exciting new
possibilities so i guess this is a story
of how it changed our lives maybe it
will yours too i mean this kid grew up
to be a [ __ ] mass murderer just and
now i can't even get offline no matter
what
it's really great
all i do is watch nature killing nature
i saw a video of a bear eating a yak the
other day and the yak couldn't have been
more than three months old
all i do is look at the computer
i really su the only the only instagram
handle i subscribe to is nature is metal
to the internet
take a spin now you're in with the
techno set you're going surfing on the
internet
i didn't know that was coming
that was the most jingliest jingle of
all time dude
i mean jesus christ that makes butt up
seem like a song from brian mcknight
unfucking real dude
that makes the [ __ ]
men men
men men men men looks like it's written
by [ __ ] bach
are you [ __ ] me that was the most
jingliest jingle ever ever
take a spin what the [ __ ] did it say the
most ninety [ __ ] of all time let's see
what i've got here we go dude take a
spin on the internet i'm doing something
unreal dude it's really cool the
internet is a whole world of exciting
new possibilities
so i guess this is a story of how it's
grew up to be a mass murderer maybe it
will yours he's on see no evil there's a
special of him evil take a spin now
you're in with the techno set you're
going surfing on the internet
you're going surfing on the
internet braille dude unbelievable dude
that is unbelievable oh my god that's
the song i want to walk down walk down
to when i'm getting married
oh my god dude that's what i'm getting
done dude chris is going to come down
like [ __ ]
[Music]
and then pointing to the [ __ ] guy and
being like i do
you going surfing on the internet
wow the most 90s [ __ ] i've ever seen in
my life dude george hamilton looked at
that video and [ __ ] fainted that's
how 90s it is
[ __ ] inaccess saw that and they go we
got to give up music that's how [ __ ]
90s it is i swear to god duran duran saw
that all four of them [ __ ] themselves
that's how 90s it was that's 80s but no
honestly insane dude the ninja turtles
goes you know what not cowabunga that's
what they did
it's the most ninety [ __ ] i've ever seen
in my life
as rich told you we installed the
internet on our computer nothing more
90s than a guy named rich too this is
all unbelievable dude
a short time ago and i haven't been able
to get the kids off it ever since not
only do they play the typical computer
games that all the kids enjoy but their
curiosity for learning has skyrocketed
peter is constantly quoting sports
statistics and he can tell you the best
surfing spots around the globe not to
mention the improvement
is great so basically you just made him
a rain man
peter can tell you any statistic in
baseball and where the best surfing
spots are and he's just like
malibu
frank thomas had a 420 slugging
percentage in
1990
last year
cancer virginia had a [ __ ] 320 second
percentage last year
surfing on the internet braille
and dashes too
having the internet in our home has had
a great impact on our lives yeah richard
stock market and our investments and i'm
able to pay the bills every time it used
to take me and the kids are improving in
their grades and communication skills
which makes me happy as i would sure
like them to go to college someday oh
dude you gotta be [ __ ] [ __ ] me
rich
which makes me happy because i would
sure like to them for them to go to
college one day dude college existed
before [ __ ] aol
they could have still gone dude
my son's gonna be a regular doogie
howser
ring ding dong ding dong
bum dude that's how it should have been
the doogee hazard theme so it should
have been me doing that
not [ __ ]
the [ __ ] stupid chimey [ __ ] dude neil
patrick harris huh how about a [ __ ]
career that [ __ ] had that guy
just never stopped working hey had
doogie hauser wind up in the matrix
had a hap
had a hap
just [ __ ]
i know kung fu and they were just like
dude we're going to make the sequel you
know what i'm thinking what
do
doom
bring a kanga brain
sir what's wrong sorry that's just the
dewy houser theme song execs in the
[ __ ] guy could you imagine if you had
a meeting like that and you did that
[ __ ] that'd be amazing well guys you
know who i'm thinking for the new mr
smith agent smith who
dude
[ __ ] yeah dude and i like that because i
sure would like my kid to go to college
one day
[ __ ] like college was just invented
in the 90s
like byu wasn't in [ __ ]
wasn't made whenever the [ __ ] john smith
or justice smith
this is in the middle of the video
wow now we need to open our browser
what's a browser [ __ ] off an application
that allows you to access all of the
different information on the internet
microsoft internet explorer came with
our computer but you can download it by
typing
www.microsoft.com wow how much is that
gig hiv when he turned 40.
it's unbelievable dude i love it
pop i that [ __ ] jingle dude
unbelievable quick the germans are
cramming
i never go
michael caine on it teaching acting in
film
how could it be
acting
michael kane on acting in film here we
go acting phil is the most [ __ ] sucker
way to say that
we're going to talk a little while about
film acting which i've done
i've done don't know if you know me i'm
in 900 movies
and the first thing that will happen
to the audience
is of course for the rest of the day
they will be completely ignored
because you don't exist
so
[ __ ]
dick the whole thing
i don't know if you know but of course
we know i've done of course he's done it
film acting which i've done
we're going to talk
for a little while about wow film acting
which i've done i mean we know well how
do you know i've done it because you've
done 950 movies and you always say i'll
do it
a little bit
and the first thing that will happen
to the audience
is of course for the rest of the day
they will be completely ignored
because you don't exist dick my fellow
actors and i can regard you as the crew
right
and once you're in front of that camera
nobody
exists how much is it mildly nobody
except the other person you're all
blacks in the scene
and what we do we actors who are in the
movie we hang on to each other's eyes oh
god damn dude you know just the [ __ ]
just say the lines right how about that
i mean it's you know it's like it's like
the acting they make it so hard because
it's not hard and they have to otherwise
they'll realize they're pieces of [ __ ]
you know
like there's guys out there literally
building
houses
so people won't die from the cold
and these guys are actors that are just
like
hang on to their eyes
i mean imagine a [ __ ] construction
worker
just like
working to make [ __ ] nine dollars an
hour
listening to michael kane you don't
exist
no matter what you don't exist it's the
most important thing you felt
eyes eyes if you're fair and you've got
blonde eyelashes like i have
you wear mascara because if you have
blonde eyelashes
and you're in a movie you might as well
be in a radio play
in the cinema it's a very very
infinitesimal space you have in which to
work it's crazy how actors [ __ ] how
important they are dude it's crazy how
important they are it's crazy how people
[ __ ]
you know i don't know i mean do it i was
in [ __ ] stuff and like i i you know i
get it but it's like just saying the
lines dude just relax bro just relax
sometimes i would be looking at the
other actors and they'd be [ __ ]
saying things to me and literally i'm
thinking about burgers i don't give a
[ __ ]
i got secrets in my head you know what i
mean
i got [ __ ] secrets in my head dude
that i'm thinking of i'm not even
thinking of this scene i already know
the lines dude say whatever you got to
say so i could do my [ __ ]
say we got to say and so i could respond
dude
i really enjoy you guys
i kind of want to watch a little bit of
more of that [ __ ] 90s thing i just
[ __ ] hang a little bit longer let's
just hang a little bit longer
it's fun dude i was cause i'm going to
watch this it was i was going to watch
this anyway
so i might as well watch it with you
guys
let's just skip ahead a little bit the
music dude
[Music]
let's go back to the hooligans homepage
and find a game oh my
[Music]
[ __ ] yeah do the most surfing music and
they're surfing the net
activity pages battleship
fruit game
web cube tic-tac-toe name that tune they
sure have a lot of them oh so drunk dude
you're right dasha but the tour was
awesome i can't believe how easy it is
to surf the net
[Music]
oh dude
so let's review a few of the concepts
we've been working on just to make sure
i understand them
first we need to get an isp or internet
service provider it connects you to the
net through high speed lines then i
downloaded wow dude look at this [ __ ]
uh first of all this video is [ __ ] 30
minutes
hi you're done after five
you're done after five dude
oh here's another one the family guy to
computers
we'd like to share with you one dude wow
oh my god how to send an email
with the assistance of the outside
broadcast unit here we go we will be
linking from the database yes if she has
public sleeves or not
pat green and julian welcome to database
hello jane hello jane julian i see you
have your computer linked to the
telephone line can you tell us how you
did that yes well it's very simple
really hasn't [ __ ] blinked dude she's
like this
and the guy it's very simple really oh
my god this is amazing dude um the
telephone is connected to the telephone
network with a british telecom plug and
i simply remove the telephone jack from
the telecom socket put it into this box
here the modem
i then take another one
and plug it in where the telephone was
switch on the modem and we're ready to
go
so nervous
so nervous if you didn't ask me if i was
just moved
and it's now telling me to phone up the
main preschool computer so nervous this
guy
um
so it's a very simple connection to me
um
jane would you like to move have you
deceased
extremely simple oh um
and i can actually leave the modem
plugged in once it's done that without
affecting the telephone
i'm now waiting for the computer to
answer me
oh so nervous dude
um on that i'm out switching the i'm not
waiting for the computer to answer me
somebody has his family at home at
gunpoint
unbelievable
and then i just flick a switch on the
modem
and replace the receiver
so difficult and
things are starting to happen i think
this is oh so general he's not going to
computer is now asking me to enter my
own personal password so worried
everyone's going to see it
which i have now done jane hasn't moved
and it comes why is jane closure the
computer he's reaching over
dude james took his computer and he's
reaching over and she's just like
dude
i know an opening screen so nervous
and julian can you tell me what is micro
net
well micronets basically is have you
ever heard a more nervous person in the
world well the thing is
michael ned i have to go home to my
family
the um
my grenade is sure my daughter and my
son are okay i um
see all ransom no i need to put the
deposit into the mailbox i am
out of prestel that's specially designed
for microcomputer users it has a lot of
facilities it has a magazine type page
of what's new today the daily news
reviews of the current software that's
available there's a letters page so
people can write in
um
how is somebody so nervous dude how is
somebody
not understand that he's acting so
nervous even if he's not nervous
programs
at something is the most nervous bit
[ __ ] you could do
um
you can load down using his middle
finger to point on belief
phone line some of them are free some of
them you do have to pay for
now pat whose computer is it well it's a
cooperative really and we all have a
part share
but julian and i mainly use it i mean so
shady
julian and i mainly use it
for things that are pure only
and
why did you buy a computer
well what if she just said where the
[ __ ] do you get off
very interested in the new technology
and didn't want to be left behind i
don't think it's only for the youngsters
at school now i think us older ones will
have to learn a lot about it and what do
you use the computer for well for
keeping household records such as uh
what i have in the freezer and
you
you gotta be
[ __ ] kidding me dude
what do you use a computer for household
records like things i have in the
freezer dude that was something she said
people's telephone numbers and addresses
i use it as a word processor for my
letters which always come out perfect
now
and um
the most exciting thing i i find is cox
you can see any mailbox
where i write to other people
on the prestel system are they is there
somebody behind the camera with ak-47
saying if you [ __ ] up you die i mean i
can't believe these people dude also
where did the other guy go
and who have you written to recently you
got any examples
yes
i sent a message to my doctor asking for
a repeat prescription
and
um
the thing is i'm schizophrenic i often
see people that aren't there
he's left the prescription for me in the
chemist
right well thank you very much pat and
julian we'll be seeing you later in the
program bye bye
if you have anything you want to do
bro that is so british i can't even
believe it wow that's unbelievable what
a [ __ ] happy accident finding that uh
wow the date to base dude well guys
that's the end of the episode on youtube
if you want the rest of the episode the
extended episode go to
patreon.comcrystalia and boy is it a
[ __ ] doozy today so go over
patreon.com
crystalia and sign up you're gonna also
get uh all of the backlogged free we do
a an episode uh an extra episode every
month on patreon you can watch all those
and just it's a fun time we got a
discord we chat we have a good time get
on the patreon patreon.com thanks
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
i mean the most 90s thing of all time
bam bam bam hey there